bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité contemporaine
vous regardez l'inattendu et vous êtes
les bienvenus là monsieur bonsoir je
voudrais regarder la france au fond des
yeux ligne j'aimerais beaucoup que les
jeunes apprennent à tricoter d'accord là
dessus
à votre place je la ramène un peu moins
mais si vous ne réussissez pas c'est
qu'il vous manque qu'une seule chose un
tout petit détail le confédéralisme à
paris ce qui lui arrive à la bleue à mes
côtés géraldine corner lavaud et tarifs
qu'aldi journaliste à la rédaction de
l'ina bonjour à tous les deux vous avez
sélectionné deux archives un qui trouve
un écho avec l'actualité des derniers
jours géraldine ce qui vous a interpellé
c'est le débat autour des black blocks
dans les récentes manifestations contre
la loi sécurité globale oui on l'a vu
dans beaucoup de journaux 1
qui sont ils que veulent t'ils les
questions autour des black blocks sont
nombreuses moi j'ai voulu savoir à
partir de quand dans les jt français on
a médiatisé ce mouvement plupart plus
précisément plutôt ce mode d'action car
c'est un mode d'action avant tout alors
les premières fois c'est dans les années
80 à berlin car il défend des des squats
ensuite le mouvement s'est exportée dans
les années 90 mais la première fois
qu'on a un reportage vraiment fouiller
avec le mot black blocks c'est en 2001
et c'est après le sommet du g8 à gênes
on les a baptisés black block blocs
noirs en anglais parce que le plus
souvent ils s'habillent et se couvrent
le visage en noir avant de passer à
l'action simple signe distinctif
le groupe n'a rien d'homogène ces blocs
noirs étaient ce les mêmes qui se
battaient assiette leur 99 lors du
sommet de l' omc ou dans les rues de
göteborg le mois dernier à l'occasion du
sommet européen
le problème pour nous c'est qu'ils
s'immiscent parmi les autres groupes de
manifestants
c'est pour cela que c'est difficile pour
les forces de l'ordre de les isoler ils
ont du coup un avantage sur nous pour
commettre le désert
alors voilà ce que disait ce policier en
2001 n'a pas changé aujourd'hui
les policiers disent la même chose les
forces de l'ordre ont toujours du mal à
isoler c'est black box parce que ils se
mêlent aux manifestants une technique
qui est donc très efficace tout autre
chose avec vous tarik on va danser aux
jeux olympiques de paris en 2024 le céou
validé l'entrée du break dance
au programme des jeux next une forme de
reconnaissance à pour cette tare cette
discipline sportive à part entière qui
vient de la rue donc là ça fait ouais ça
existe deux aux états unis depuis les
années 70 en france depuis un peu plus
tard savait toujours un peu de temps à
la différence avec le hip hop le il a
passé englobe encore toi que toutes les
disciplines de la rue que ce soit le rap
le deejaying aussi ça vient du hip hop
et le breakdance et le breakdance la
danse le break dance se popularise en
france dans les années 70 on va voir un
peu comment en parler avec un
présentateur que vous connaissez tous
noël mamère
avec un peu de difficulté vous allez
voir je veux parler de la break dance
cette nouvelle danse qui fait fureur
auprès des jeunes générations avec le
smur
je crois aussi regarder ses voltiges et
ses toupies partie improvisé qu'il n'y a
pas dans le réseau la danse jazz
très construit les mouvements c'est sûr
très technique et là il ya bon seuil
technique info la plus folle à la pige
et la comprendre tout une fois qu'on l'a
jadis qu'on peut inventer plein de trucs
on peut jouer avec son corps
imaginez on peut inventer des choses on
peut le faire à plusieurs cette équipe
aussi ça me peine d'apprendre à proton a
vu les images comme ça qui passait à la
télévision pour la première fois on l'a
vu des gens qui faisait des trucs
absolument incompréhensible tourner sur
la tête sur les épaules sur les bras on
voit ça on comprend pas alors on vient
dans les cours pour comprendre comment
ça se passe et à ce moment là en plus en
partir le smur
comment voit-il code civil à auby
reconnu désormais donc parmi l'élite des
sports eh ben j'ai hâte de voir ce que
ça va être donné en 2024
voilà ça c'était l'actualité de la
semaine que s'est il passé le 9 décembre
à travers le temps à regarder le zapping
de l'ina ça s'est passé à 9 décembre
bonjour
derrière le cercueil blanc du chanteur
700 bikers venus de toute la france
c'était une volonté de johnny hallyday
un dernier spectacle un ultime décor
grandiose cadeau de la star à ses
admirateurs le ministre de la famille et
celui de la justice ont en effet lancé
un appel conjoint pour demander à leurs
compatriotes de ne plus offrir à leurs
enfants des jouets qui rappelle la
guerre
j'imagine que la guerre c'est terrible
mais quand je joue je n'y pense que la
bombe
enfin une bombe semblable à celle qui
avait plus qu ils ont échoué à peu près
ce qui a été un grand bonheur que dieu
m'a procuré parce qu'avant j'ai compris
après avoir échappé à la filature des
policiers polonais nous retrouvons dans
une petite pièce face à lech walesa je
me sens tout petit normal
ordina ordinaire aujourd'hui pas facile
de rester un homme simple lorsqu'on a un
prix nobel
comme je lé dinh
et il ne m'appartient pas mal de
l'apprécier je ne sais pas j'essaie de
vous continuer à faire ce que je fais et
ce fut vraiment la star de la journée et
l'on sait presque battu pour faire avec
lui
ce dernier voyage au soir et à demain
[Musique]
nos espèces sonnantes et trébuchantes
ont-elles encore un avenir alors que le
paiement sans contact s'est
considérablement accélérée pendant le
confinement
la commission européenne a lancé une
grande consultation ouverte à tous
faut-il retirer de la circulation les
pièces de 1 et de 2 centimes de la
petite monnaie encombrante à qui fait
râler les français et ce n'est pas
nouveau
géraldine c'est pas nouveau un bien
avant les centimes d'euro en cliff que
vous avez peut-être là dans vos poches
dans les années 70 souvenez vous il y
avait des centimes de francs qui
encombrent et les portefeuilles des
pièces de un centime et de deux centimes
et écouter ce lancement de roger gicquel
célèbre présentateur qui nous expliquait
à quel point ça devenait encombrants oui
voilà un petit peu d'argent qui n'a plus
beaucoup de valeur
personne ne dit plus un sou c'est un sou
tout simplement parce que 5 centimes ce
n'est plus grand chose et un centime ce
n'est plus rien du tout voilà le un
centime qu'on appelait également
centimes confettis et la pièce de 2
centimes vont progressivement arrêté
d'être frappés et les prix
s'arrondissent de 55
assez naturellement oui et assez
naturellement aussi les français vont
complètement oublié ses pièces de 1 et 2
centimes à elles disparaissent de la
circulation
coincé sûrement dans un coup simple
canapé ou au fond d'un vieux manteau et
regarder dans les années 80 on leur
demande même s'ils se souviennent de ces
pièces-là écouter leurs réponses est ce
que tu es encore des pièces de la chan
ting
deux cents à nous et vous ça n'existait
annonce à ce que ça n'existe plus un
centime
bien que 5 centimes quand vous avez à
payer avec des sentiments dans port
distant plus affable vincent teneur de 1
centime ça n'existe pas vous aimez faire
la france est néanmoins fait cadeau ça
n'existe pas enfin on arrive dans les
années 90 si ces petits sous 2 1 et 2
centimes ont complètement disparu
et là seulement des pièces de 5 10 20
centimes mais même là encore ses troupes
au combat
oui c'est trop encombrant 1 5 10 20
centimes mais quelqu'un a la solution
plutôt une association ou une fondation
pardon c'est la fondation des hôpitaux
de paris avec et puis évidemment voilà
les plus jeunes ils ont réussi à allier
l'utile donc se débarrasser de cette
callas qui pèsent lourd au fond des
poches à l'agréable améliorer les
conditions de vie et des enfants
hospitalisés
en 1991 c'est la première édition
nationale des pièces jaunes et la
promotion se faisait en plateau écouter
vous n'avez de que les enfants bien
portants viennent aider les enfants
malades à l'hôpital en recueillant de la
petite monnaie souvent les parents et
les papas notamment le soir enlève de
leur poche la paix les petites pièces et
les déposer souvent les enfants de
l'iran sont les destinataires et bien là
on leur demande non pas de le mettre
dans les tirelires mais peut-être
d'affaires la collecte autour d'eux
avait pas encore bernadette chirac
voilà on pensait être débarrassé à cette
époque un de ces petites pièces mais
patatras tout s'écroule
le 1er janvier 2002 avec l'arrivée de
l'euro l'arrivée de l'euro signe le
grand retour des pièces de 1 et 2
centimes donc ces petites pièces en
cuivre elles sont aujourd'hui on vous
l'avait dit dans le viseur mais déjà dès
leur arrivée donc 1er janvier 2002 elle
faisait râler les français le meilleur
endroit pour s'en rendre compte c'est lé
marché
regardez avec mes lunettes horreur de
loin je vois pas les flics ul de frais
j'étais trop beaucoup trop petit c'est
un débat bien on est un peu perdu avec
les tikis oui alors on va s'y faire mais
il faudra bien revenir pauvrement
arrondie au centime
pourquoi faut aller aux 510 maintenant
plus chaud en penser qu'il ya trop de
toutes pièces a chanté un chant tiennent
deux euros je vais vous montrer ce que
c'est d'être un idiot moi c'était pas
que j'avais 12 ans mais je t'ai bien que
moi de pouvoir acheter des petits
bonbons quand même si vous avez acheté
plus de bonbons aujourd'hui paris combo
crois pas de clans s'opposent à ceux qui
veulent les supprimer et ceux qui
militent pour leur maintien afin
d'éviter une augmentation des prix
géraldine et oui et ce sont exactement
les mêmes arguments aujourd'hui un lait
pour garder caisse quand ceux qui
veulent garder ses pièces de 1 et 2
centimes disent que ça permet d'avoir
des prix justes ceux qui veulent les
enlever
la crainte c'est de se dire on va
arrondir à 5 centimes au-dessus faire
voilà mais seulement il ya un nouvel
argument qui vient en défaveur de ces
petites pièces de 20 à 2 centimes c'est
que leur coût de fabrication est plus
élevé que leur valeur donc ça coûte plus
cher de femmes trappe et une pièce de un
centime
c'est à peu près 3 centimes d'euro pour
frapper une pièce d'un centime
voilà c'est pourquoi la commission
réfléchit aujourd'hui à les supprimer
et puis ce rite le paiement sans contact
s'est considérablement développée ces
derniers mois voilà fins de consultation
en tout cas en janvier prochain et la
sentence devrait tomber à la fin de
l'année 2021 certains pays comme la
belgique la finlande 10 ronan l'irlande
ou bien les pays-bas les ont d'ailleurs
déjà abandonné ces petites pièces en
cuivre
[Musique]
voilà un siècle que notre pays désigne
chaque année l'ambassadrice du charme à
la française
l'élection miss france fête ses 100 ans
nous allons parler de ce rendez vous de
fin d'année avec notre invité sonia
rolland bonjour miss france 2000 membres
du jury cette année
quelles doivent être les qualités d'une
miss france en 2021 faculté d'adaptation
à tous les environnements sociaux et
culturels enfin en fait on a je pense
qu'on défende tout les mêmes choses puis
deux puis des puits et des 10 une
centaine d'années maintenant puisqu'elle
fait les 100 ans alors l'une des clés du
succès de miss france c'est bien sûr la
télévision au tout début en 1920
première année de miss france elle
n'existait pas il a fallu attendre les
années 80 pour voir une émission dédiée
comme celle que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
des attaques
et oui on l'a vu en 1986 sa toute
première émission en fait c'était une
triple première donc vous l'avez dit
première fois qu'on a ce show retransmis
en direct première fois aussi que les
téléspectateurs peuvent voter un par
téléphone en appelant vote pour une miss
est aussi premier cafouillage au pire
moment celui de l' annonce à la deuxième
dauphine donc c'est là la réunion avec
joël ramia
il me serait idiot
est ce que vous êtes sûr de votre
placement je vous invite tout à l'heure
que les parisiens étaient plus se
tourner vers la chaleur
attendez attendez ou est-ce que j'en
suis 2e dauphine deuxième dauphine
qu'est-ce qui se passe
bush qu'est-ce qu'elle a notre miss elle
se fâche tabac une mise proteste elle
dit que pourtant pour la première fois
c'est le public qui vote personne ne
voit la différence quand même c'est que
on devient miss france habillée on épure
vous imaginez vous que ça vous arrive ça
saoule roulant d'imaginer sur vous et à
le cafouillage mais ça existe encore
aujourd'hui j'ai vu il n'ya pas si
longtemps à miss univers aussi ça dépend
en fait si on présente la dauphine où la
miss france celle qui va gagner ou celle
qui enfin voila mais sacré que c'était
nouveau aligné en regardant d'extraits
vous nous avez dit tiens c'était guy lux
tiens je me souviens de cette de cette
élection de 1986 parce que c'est jour de
l élection qui vous a donné envie de
devenir ou d'essayer de devenir miss
france voilà j'ai un parcours très
spécial en fait moi c'est vraiment par
le biais du hasard sur un terrain de
basket qu'un monsieur est venu me
proposer de me présenter à miss
bourgogne
alors moi j'étais très étonné pour deux
choses déjà j'étais pas du tout c'est
minime et et oui mais en plus parce que
on est grand oui c'est vrai que sur les
teintes parce qu'elles sont grandes mais
j'ai je suis métisse et je me disais
j'avais jamais vu de métis miss france
est d'origine africaine donc c'était une
première et miss bourgogne
donc il y avait une vraie symbolique que
j'avais envie de défendre quand même
donc je me suis jetée dans cette
aventure folle et puis ça a marché on va
on va revenir sur votre élection
j'aimerais juste que vous me racontiez
dans quel état d'esprit on est le soir
d'une finale comme celle là comme celle
que l'on vient de devoir en 1986 qu'est
ce qui se passe dans la tête d'une mise
sur le podium avec ben avec le vote et
vous en souvenez oui tout dépend de la
pression que la miss va vivre il ya des
il ya des régions qui sont très fortes
sur lesquels on mise beaucoup sur
certaines listes qui représente des
régions très chaud zina qui sont portés
par un élan de solidarité comme ça
derrière et c'est moi par exemple je
venais de la bourgogne c'est plutôt
discrète plutôt outside 2 vous voyez pas
du tout miss france je dis pas dans les
favorites
du coup ça a été une énorme surprise
pour moi et puis dans un contexte à la
fois politique et culturelle qui était
complètement dingue à l'époque c'était
vraiment la france black blanc beur on
sortait de la victoire des bleus voilà
et il y avait un vent favorable à cette
diversité auquel je pense j'ai répondu
et du coup moi j'ai surfé sur cette
vague
alors après l'élection après après la
victoire il ya les voyages il ya le la
mode ya les plateaux télé ça peut faire
rêver mais une miss ne fait pas toujours
ce qu'elles me tarik un an dans un an
vous ne dirait pas le contraire la tenue
irréprochable est exigée attention aux
faux pas lors on se souvient de valérie
bègue en 2007 pour des photos dénudées
dans le même genre engagé j'ai trouvé
dans les archives une autre histoire
celle d' isabelle turpault miss france
1983 aussi pour des photos dénudées paru
dans paris match alors en fait on devine
un peu ses seins sous un voile s'est pas
non plus incroyables même nous raconter
tout ça quelques mois après son éviction
ce ne sont pas des photos licencieuses
ce sont des photos des photos de pardon
de salut et je trouve que bon en 1983
il est possible de qu'une miss france
montre sa poitrine
quand c'est bien fait j'ai mon caractère
ma personnalité je suis donc isabelle
turpault je suis moi même je suis pas un
objet est sale n'a pas mis bon nous
devons faire ça à quelle heure et le
choc une poupée mécanique poupée
mécanique ccc fort vous voulez commencer
quelque chose assez violent quand même
content d'être destitué pour sa fin
c'est compliqué quand même je pense que
c'était une féministe avant l'heure et
elle a eu bien fait de le défendre
malgré tout essayer par exemple moi j'ai
connu les années madame de fontenay et
c'était c'était c'est un sujet sur
lequel on pouvait débattre avec elle
parce que par exemple elle ne trouvait
pas moche
l'idée qu'une femme soit nu mais
photographiée par par exemple helmut
newton
elle trouvait celui là très beau et et
en même temps elle avait un peu peur de
la vulgarité
ce qui est compliqué c'est qu'on est
surexposé en tant que miss france on est
un peu la fiancée des français
la la
oui la fille l'avait fait rêver ça met
beaucoup justement c'est ce truc où il
faut être solidaire j'avais beaucoup oui
ça aide mais puis c'est une autre époque
aussi aujourd'hui si vous voulez avec
les réseaux sociaux avec cette
surexposition auxquels font face
beaucoup de jeunes femmes et cette
espèce de d'hypersexualisation c'est un
peu compliqué aussi de savoir où met le
curseur de cette vulgarité ou pas c'est
cette nudité justement c'est vrai que
cette année de miss qui suit donc
l'élection ça fait ça fait rêver les
petites filles
est-ce que c'est agréable à vivre pour
les miss l'année de miss france pas
toujours
moi je préfère être honnête évidemment
qu'il ya quelque chose d'incroyable
parce qu'on bascule dans dans une forme
de fantasmes et de rêves mais après il
ya aussi le revers de la médaille on est
quand même sujette aux critiques
constamment de la part des féministes de
la part de ceux qui trouvent que c'est
désuet que c'est pas du tout la place de
la femme mais en même temps de l'autre
côté on se pose pas la question de est
ce que nous a forcés à se présenter ou
autres contraire est-ce que c'est pas
une manière de défendre justement une
forme de féminité
tout est discutable et moi je pense que
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est ça reste
un show télévisé
les femmes sont là très heureuse de se
présenter très bien mais s'il faut tirer
sur des femmes ou en tout cas s'il faut
défendre un féminisme c'est pas à cet
endroit là il ya bien des causes à
défendre aujourd'hui votre élection cela
c'est aussi un symbole puisque vous êtes
y est la première miss france d'origine
africaine
sept ans après l'élection de véronique
de la cruz qui était elle même
guadeloupéen miss guadeloupe et noir et
noir
ça c'était important pour vous j'imagine
mais surtout pour vos parents qu'on va
écouter dans un reportage à l'époque de
france 3 bourgogne
voilà là et les mamans africaines qui a
envoyé une lettre formidable parce que
la maman il dit il ya on a toujours
parlé des voleurs s'étaient des
africains des malades du sida c'était
des africains des drogués c'était des
africains mais pour une fois on a une
enfant une beauté africaine qui émergent
qui est donc nettement avec elle aussi
que vous ne parlez que de l'afrique au
nord de la france aussi parce que je
suis métisse et l'amour quand même fait
beaucoup de choses entre deux eaux de
ross on arrive à faire à créer quelque
chose le beauf ouais bon j'avais 18 ans
un non et puis surtout vous savez quand
vous êtes métis vous avez vous n'avez
vous nagez entre deux eaux vous avez
toujours le cul entre deux chaises
ce que je dis c'est compliqué en fait de
défendre sa double culture quand on doit
représenter une francs une fluence une
france plurielle et une france pour pour
certains qui est pas encore tout à fait
prête à voir émerger des miss d'origine
africaine c'était très compliqué c'est
moi j'ai fait face aussi à une un
questionnement c'est que je suis pas
créole par exemple les seuls miss
métissé où à la carnation comme la
mienne était d'origine créole ou
antillaise donc du coup c'était une
nouveauté pour tout le monde même pour
les antilles eve non est-ce que vous
avez des des jolies filles qui sont
venus nous voir après votre élection en
me disant ça a changé quelque chose pour
moi de vous voir devoir gagner ce qui a
eu des conséquences positives peut-être
négative
oui positive certes en fait je pense
qu'aussi elle se réfère aussi à mon
parcours depuis miss france elle voit
l'évolution qui a été la mienne après
miss france parce que je pense pas
qu'elle faisait souvenir de mon année de
miss france elle voit le parcours qui a
été fait depuis
et c'est vrai que ça les inspire
certainement alors souvent elles
viennent me demander si j'ai une clé la
clé de la réussite jeu
10 la constance la rigueur la
détermination aussi parce qu'on fait
face
quand même à beaucoup de préjugés mois
en devenant comédienne ça a été très
compliqué parce que on m'attendait pas
forcément là il ya aussi il faut faut
réaliser quand même qu'il ya des gens
qui ont fait un parcours inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'il ils ont progressé
dans un en apprenant leur métier moi
celle un verger était connu avant de
travailler donc arriver avec les en
prétendant être connu bah c'est pas tout
il faut aussi pouvoir connecter pendant
lequel on veut évoluer donc faut faire
preuve d'humilité et de patience alors
on va parler de votre carrière dans un
instant d'abord tariq
j'aimerais que vous me disiez que vous
nous disiez ce que deviennent les miss
élues à cette élection allait aller
tremplin vers la mode vers le cinéma
vers la télévision est ce qu il en a
toujours été non à l'ours est tous à la
mode le cinéma mais aussi parfois des
désillusions
on va voir ça avec des miss qui nous
raconte en 1983 m toujours avec le
sourire et photographe nous prouve aussi
en général de faire des photos de nu
mais c'est assez normal dans la mesure
où bon pour faire du nu pour poser nue
il faut que la fille soit jolie donc par
définition miss france étant joly on
nous propose ça on me l'a proposé pour
que les bugs notamment j'ai refusé pour
la proposer pratiquement lutte et miss
france
faire du nu sur les magazines lui à
l'époque où j'étais mais ce point c'est
bien entendu avec l'écharpé vous
heureusement j'ai envie de dire on
appelle cette option du menu
croyez-moi quand on est comédienne en
fait mais bon ce dépend comment on peut
refuser toute façon oui déjà on peut
refuser après
on vit plus vraiment la même époque vous
savez les femmes ont quand même il ya
une sororité aujourd'hui qu'ils
s'expriment les femmes sont beaucoup
plus solidaire beaucoup plus forte
et puis et puis ça inspire forcément les
plus jeunes et elles se disent
qu'aujourd'hui elles peuvent dire non si
elles le veulent quoi ça vous aurez
c'est vrai que c'est un peu agaçant
quand même ça vous a servi ou ça vous à
des services ce titre de miss france
dans votre carrière et votre envie de
devenir comédienne moi ça m'a servi
parce que on acquiert une notoriété donc
pour certains projets c'est sûr que vous
avez dans des cases force évidemment un
peu forcément vous mettre dans une case
moi je suis incapable je suis métisse
donc je suis ni noire ni blanche pas
assez noir face à ces blanche pour
certains rôles j'ai été miss france donc
je symbolise finalement pour certains
quelque chose d'assez désuet peut-être
un peu trop féminisé donc trop hills et
puis pour d'autres c'est une super
opportunité parce que finalement on
brasse énormément de public aussi ça il
faut le reconnaître
alors on en parle un petit peu moins
mais vous êtes quelqu'un de très engagé
notamment auprès des des enfants en
afrique au rwanda vous est la marraine
de la fabrique nomades qui valorise les
métiers des réfugiés vous avez commencé
à vous engager à quel moment c'était
déjà pendant votre votre règne si je
puis me permettre
disons que quand on devient miss oui on
est très sollicité par les associations
puisqu'on est un porte-voix assez facile
en finalement et mais très vite quand
j'ai fait mon grand retour au rwanda
parce que j'avais quitté dans les années
90 il et j'ai eu une prise de conscience
je me suis dit qu'un voilà si mal dans
ma peau de ma notoriété doit servir à
quelque chose il faut que qu'elle serve
voilà aux sans voix et en l'occurrence
le rwanda c'était un sujet qui était
presque méconnus ou alors que à travers
le prisme du génocide des tutsi du
rwanda et du coup je voulais qu'on
prenne en considération le fait qu'il y
a
un peuple qui souffre 60% de la
population avait moins de 40 ans à
l'époque et il fallait qu'on prenne à
bras le corps ce sujet du coup voilà
j'ai créé mon association qui s'appelle
mme aïcha africa que qui existe depuis
20 ans maintenant et et puis je suis
aussi la marraine de la fabrique nomade
mais qui elle vient en aide aux artisans
réfugié en france des as 10 artisans
migrants qui ont acquis qu'ils ont
laissés dans leur dans leur pays et
qu'ils peuvent bénéficier d'une
formation ici pour intégrer des maisons
de couture ou des design mais qui
valorise et favorise leur intégration
professionnelle en insertion
professionnelle sonia rolland merci
beaucoup pour cet éclairage sur cette
élection de miss france
rappelons que chaque année à l'émission
est un succès puisqu'elle rassemble 6 à
7 millions de téléspectateurs
miss france 2000 21 sera élu c'est dans
dix jours merci à vous en tout cas
d'être venu sur ce plateau voilà c'est
terminé pour l'inattendu on se retrouve
mercredi prochain à 21h sur le canal 27
et bien sûr toute la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux se devine à ceux de
france info et merci à vous d'être
présent